a third day of Border chaos hundreds of
tour groups the majority of them
children stranded for up to 20 hours
many have had little sleep and little to
eat besides crisps
predictions by Port Authorities that
normal service would resume by Sunday
were wide of the mark now we've been
told that for every coach in front of
you it's going to be an hour so I think
we were four four coaches back we're
gonna go and get pizzas now but we're
we're fingers crossed that the police
officer is right with an hour each and I
don't turn up back with 50 pizzas and no
students
according to France is only part of the
battle coach drivers are reaching their
shift limits with no one to drive the
rest of the way some teachers are being
forced to give up one of the worst
conversations
um they took it really well but they're
obviously disappointed and conflated
um we are looking at sorting out future
options in the future but obviously that
that's not the time for now
um the parents have been really really
supportive and understanding as to
what's causing all this well it's
apparently very high demand over the
Easter holidays it's partly bad weather
disrupting Crossings and creating a
backlog but then there's the inescapable
fact that because of brexit it now takes
considerably longer to process the
passengers passports than it did before
and according to one travel expert it's
about to get much worse the only
compensation you have is the emotional
compensation of having a blue British
passport these people are having an
absolutely horrible time and I'm so
sorry and it's going to get worse
because the entry exit system again
which we signed up for is going to
require all those people on those
coaches to have their facial Biometrics
taken and their fingerprints the homes
secretary denied brexit was to blame and
instead urged people to have patience
should such chaos become a regular
occurrence though the Public's patience
may be stretched